SPEAKER: More and more companies
are looking to unlock business
insights from their data.
But it can be hard to scalably
ingest, store, and analyze
that data as it rapidly grows.
Google's enterprise data
warehouse, BigQuery,
was designed to make
large-scale data analysis
accessible to everyone.
In this series,
we'll show you how
BigQuery can help you
get valuable insights
from your data with ease.
Ask questions and get answers
on "BigQuery Spotlight."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
If you're a developer,
data analyst,
or just about
anyone else, you're
probably working with data.
If your business has
small amounts of data,
you might be able to
store it in a spreadsheet.
But as your amount of
data grows to gigabytes,
terabytes, or even
petabytes, you
start to need a more efficient
system like a data warehouse.
That's because all that data
isn't very useful unless you
have a way to analyze it.
Traditionally,
larger sets of data
mean longer times between
asking your questions
and getting answers.
Have you ever needed to wait
hours or days for an analytics
report to be run?
BigQuery was designed to
handle massive amounts of data,
such as log data from thousands
of retail systems or IoT data
from millions of vehicle
sensors across the globe.
It's a fully managed and
serverless data warehouse
which empowers you to focus on
analytics instead of managing
infrastructure.
By design, BigQuery helps you
avoid the data silo problem
which happens when you
have individual teams
in your company having their
own independent data marts.
This can create significant
friction between analyzing data
across teams and
cause challenges
with data version control.
Thanks to the integration with
Google Cloud's native identity
and access management, you
can assign read or write
permissions to specific
users, groups, or projects,
and keep your
sensitive data secure,
all while still
collaborating across teams.
Working with data in BigQuery
involves three primary parts--
storage, ingestion,
and querying.
Google handles running
everything else.
BigQuery is a fully
managed service,
which means you don't need to
set up or install anything.
And you don't require a
database administrator.
You can simply log into
your Google Cloud project
from a browser and get started.
First, let's talk about
BigQuery's storage.
Data is stored in a
structured table, which
means that you can use standard
SQL for easy querying and data
analysis.
For example, let's
say that you have
some data that represents the
sales for each of your stores
in the last year.
You could probably use a
smaller database for that.
But what if you have
thousands of stores?
And what if you want revenue
broken up by product SKU
or by region per time period?
BigQuery is perfect
for big data because we
manage all that storage
and the scaling operations
automatically for you.
Of course, storing
the data doesn't
matter if you can't get into
BigQuery in the first place.
Thankfully, there
are lots of ways
to do that, as
BigQuery is integrated
with the rest of the data
analytics platform from Google.
You can upload data from Cloud
Storage and just streaming
data from Cloud Dataflow,
build an ETL pipeline using
Cloud data fusion, import data
from a variety of file formats,
or use a combination
of all of these.
We'll go over these and
more in future episodes
so that you can
decide which setup
is right for your data sets.
Once your data is
in BigQuery, you're
ready to start answering
those questions.
BigQuery supports the same
Structured Query Language,
or SQL, that you may
be familiar with if you
worked with ANSI-compliant
relational databases
in the past.
We'll go over multiple ways
to work with data in BigQuery
so that you can choose what's
best for your use case.
Plus, you'll be able to share
access with other users,
so they can derive insights
from your data, too.
Want to skip straight
to analyzing some data?
You can bypass the
ingestion and storage steps
by analyzing the BigQuery
public data sets.
These are third-party data sets
which have been made public
for anyone to query against.
Google handles all the
storage so that you
can focus on figuring
out answers to questions,
like, how does the
weather in New York City
affect demand for taxicabs?
In this series, we'll walk you
through the play-by-play, some
of the most common
tasks in BigQuery,
and share some best practices
to help you up your game.
But if you want to get started
right now, click on the link
below, and start with
the BigQuery sandbox.
The sandbox gives you a free
environment to trial BigQuery.
And you can get started
by analyzing public data
sets immediately.
Look out for our next episode
of "BigQuery Spotlight."
And remember, stay curious.